how are you Conan I'm great all the
better for seeing you yes I'm uh they
say that I'm the best medicine in these
times well especially with your hair
like that I mean I know it's out of
control I haven't had a haircut in a
while and when I treat it cheers me up
know an action I actually have a haircut
on Saturday just for you Oh
knowing that I was gonna be on t on TV
with you yeah clearly yeah you look very
nice clearly you cared a lot more than I
did
it's so absurd when talking to you John
did to mention just some of your credits
because you've done so much so to say
third Rock or you know or the crown it
feels like what we're not mentioning the
9000 other things you've done to great
acclaim do you what's the project you
think you hear about the most from fans
when you're walking down the street
precoded no one's got a mask on what do
people want to talk to you about well it
could just can be any number of things I
mean because of what you just said I am
this curiosity of an actor who is known
for many different things so you walk
down one block of a crowded street
something you cannot do anymore
and people will stop me for a whole
variety of things third Rock in the Sun
Dexter the crown some appearances on the
Conan O'Brien show 20 years ago right
perhaps my most memorable work I ope
[Applause]
many people have won Oscars for their
appearances on my show which is a but it
can happen it does you know third Rock
was an interesting role for you because
because you were an alien you were
allowed to as an actor display just
about anything you're able to do you
know what I mean you couldn't you could
have the superpower of showing anything
that John Lithgow can do that must have
been a real kick for you well that's
almost the definition of what was so
special about that project that role and
a big reason why I took it on do you
have a favorite moment where you got to
do something that you'd never get to do
otherwise yes I would say perhaps the
the Irish clog-dancing I did in the
episode where we parodied the Lord of
the dance
we had him for Michael Flatley we were
so determined to take him down because
he was such a smug self-important
artiste and bonny and Terry created this
this thing called the king of the jig
and I and the entire cast of the show
poured out of the theater having just
seen this and in my exhilaration I
started dancing like Michael Flatley and
then everybody did it was it was one of
those electrifying moments on 3rd Rock
which was a show where anything could
happen
just for fans and I know this was a
favorite of people's I remember this
really well we have that clip right now
[Applause]
we come back now delighted that we've
seen it yeah oh my god I I was
transported during the entire